I'm jar bowler and I'm going to do a
Google autocomplete interview am i
holding up towards the camera is Gerard
Butler Irish almost kind of I'm Scottish
but I have a lot of Irish in my family
is Gerard Butler a lot of what you guys
are gonna ask engaged no just another
internet rumor is chirp still alive no
I'm dead this interview will be my
memorial is Gerard Butler really singing
in phantom spear capital P but anyway
yes that was me singing and if you heard
the complaints of certain people about
how I sing you would know that it was
definitely me is Gerard Butler ah very
much ridiculously ticklish well they
were easy okay next one does Gerard
Butler have an Instagram do I have an
Instagram no I don't have an Instagram I
think somebody has an Instagram that
they say is me but it's not really me
but they see me do a pretty good job so
I'm not complaining
does Gerard Butler chew tobacco try it a
couple times it made me very ill so I
stick to chewing gum does Gerard Butler
still surf I do from time to time not as
much as I used to I like paddleboarding
too does Gerard have an accent in real
life
well if yeah more cut out by the end of
this interview then you should be asking
questions like this don't you are
thank you
does Jar butlered arm get tired holding
this up surprisingly yes will London has
fallen let's question will London has
fallen have a sequel what depends if you
go to see the damn thing if you do then
yes but I think so because it's awesome
well London has fallen have a happy
ending always this is about good against
evil and good always wins especially
when under good guy well London has
fallen berated are hell yeah
it's hard our baby well London has
fallen kick-ass you betcha
it's ridiculously ass-kicking and I say
that for the bottom of my heart I'm
ready I'm ready for more
you